did you have any role models in your
life any good male role models
nah
all them was murderers drug dealers
killers
had rapists on my family members
a lot of rapists in my family yeah role
models are huge you know what i'm saying
it's like
nobody never showed me that hey i got
touched on when i was like two
if i still remember to the day i got
touched on
all right miss here yeah who's here uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
i'm from fort uses virginia you feel me
but i grew up when i got older downtown
local news in the gutter so so this is a
suburb of what city
i grew up in the suburbs right this is
newport news christopher newport
university okay this is just uh not d.c
this is not not it's the south side of
the gym we're not even considered the
envy because we're so grimy we'll be
from really yeah like people getting
killed out there like i said my first
murder happened without like eight years
old [ __ ] got the brains blown out you
feel me
and my owners there's gangs out there
too yeah yeah but it's running gay
though it got bloods crips vice lords
but it's like everybody [ __ ] with each
other but then they still beef with each
other because they're cousins you all
say everybody related too
so i was like yeah
oh god so how'd you grow up you had both
your mom and dad as a kid nah my dad he
left when i was like like three two
you feel me he was he was hooked on
crack he just smoked lace blunts and all
that you feeling and my mama she did
what she could but then like she was in
the shipyard right
but then when he was like like pre-k
she had to got down got hooked on the
pills real bad
you feel me and she was doing
installation for the new canoe shipyard
you know what i'm saying so i got down
once she started doing the pills and
[ __ ] she just went downhill look so like
when she was working in the ship y'all
right right there was a pre-k she
started getting hooked on the pills
you know what i'm saying because i ain't
gonna say his name but one of her big
daddies was like he was thinking that
[ __ ] thinking drugs and [ __ ] because he
was trying to provide for what he could
provide for too you know what i'm saying
he a real [ __ ] though real [ __ ] he's
got now i'm gonna call him red you know
i'm talking about really my my sister
daddy fear me so got down
yeah man he had two texts and [ __ ] first
time i seen the gun
let me hold one of his little 38s or
something me and my brother
my mama stopped crying cause she caught
us holding a gun
every night me my brother's thinking to
the room she detect you feeling me he
had two of them
and he was like man yeah we just fell in
love with guns after that real sick you
know the gym over carry like when i was
home back home i had to carry a gun too
but back to work when i was growing up
two years like when i was like in fifth
grade though
fourth grade i seen my momma
bag of dope before in the back room of
my house and [ __ ]
helping one of her boyfriends bag of
heroin and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so like
when you moved to hampton virginia
that's why i had grew up in there we
started really like growing up in the
dope house
well like i could say that like not not
the whole time but like sometimes feel
like growing up in the dope house i'm
almost trapping you know what i'm saying
so she was doing what she could do
you feel me like
yeah
that [ __ ] it was rough out there maybe
she did what she could though my daddy
was never around he was a bone bro like
like
[ __ ] you ever meet your dad yeah i met
him before i followed him and [ __ ] in 20
in 2018 i got a fight with him in
tennessee he wouldn't move back out
there right now but it's like i said i
should be in atlanta too when i like
three four
you feeling me but some crazy ass story
happened my mom she was [ __ ] the nfl
players right she took some drugs from
her head like a they had like kids some
drugs like like cocaine or something
everybody killed my mama you feel me
yeah and my dad and them had to take me
from uh from atlanta back to tennessee
back to virginia that's why i stayed
there if they ain't never happen my mom
ain't never taken drugs from the nfl
players i would have still been in
tennessee right now atlanta i would have
never been from virginia for real so
your mom was also working as a
prostitute
uh i said escort escort yes
she's a little pimp but she's working at
nfl and you call it escort i guess right
yeah yeah she was pimping them [ __ ]
you feel i know she was doing i ain't
seen a pimp when she was pimping her
[ __ ] yeah finessing them and [ __ ] she
probably knew she had phone with him and
[ __ ] but
my momma
ain't gonna say [ __ ] hold her she just
she's like finessing [ __ ] [ __ ] she's a
hustler [ __ ] hustler yeah that's how i
get it from my brother for so he named
quality yeah so you started carrying a
gun at what age god damn
you shot we stopped playing with guns
like around 16. i dropped out in ninth
grade
i only went tonight i was only enough
great for a month
you feel me i dropped out
you know i'm saying hit break inside
houses and [ __ ] for the whole summer and
again the gang life just went full tilt
after that it was our own game renegade
[ __ ] yeah it's not the name of it but we
were some renegade young [ __ ] you feel
me it was called kdg kick though game
you feel me the feds even came in our
house like two times ain't catching with
none
i threw some [ __ ] in the roof one time
a lady police officer came in and caught
me doing it right but she didn't say no
she saved my life
you feel me she blessed me that day
she was a latino lady she didn't say
[ __ ] oh god
yeah i sell crack before i sell powder
so you were selling drugs
back home yeah last summer
you did jail or prison time yeah nah i'm
too smart for the police good for you
they never catch me they might catch me
with with my gun homie but i don't gotta
offend you so they can't do no they
might catch me with some liquor
i don't think they ain't gonna catch me
with i never ride with drunk my mom
always taught me no ride with nothing
you feeling
i'm 21. you're 21. yeah
like man i've been through some [ __ ] bro
like
in the south of virginia south side
newport news
it's crazy bruh it's crazy out there
brother you'd never think that a smaller
town like that would would be as out of
control as is that [ __ ] out there like
like what's going on right now
this little this little situation
man my homies in there with it where
they got on [ __ ] ass bro probably stop
shooting at him or something
just to get them from around the corner
or just get the situation to die down
like i got a homie i grew up with locked
up for murder right now
you feel me
you have a lot of friends who've died or
gone yeah yeah
i had two homeboy that died in the same
same goddamn same months type [ __ ]
rayquan
he from south side he died i grew up
with him but
he was [ __ ] with with people that
ain't really [ __ ] with me so i couldn't
really talk to her like that
so everybody was like
virginia was a lovely place the south
side was a lovely place in 2013 but when
the guns and then [ __ ] it the
hip-hop came out chief keith so
everybody mind stop it stop blowing up
everybody want to be like chief keith
you feel me but they ain't never grow up
like chief so everybody can't really
relate to it so i'm saying
so like
and
what that life brought you bro to drugs
you played around with drugs as well
hell yeah so i did uh eat pills
weed
uh mushrooms
see i did coke before
but i should sell it i did that i put on
my tooth it will hurt so i sniffed it
you know what i'm saying i'm feeling
good i ain't gonna count if you got a
good coat you're gonna feel good save me
biting and [ __ ]
god i ain't never did cracking them
what about today
no i did um
what's the hardest drug i did so far
i know that's no i see it
no christian no
i did though
yeah i did
one time had my body hurt you feeling me
i was up for three days yeah i had
swords and [ __ ] right here i like dang
what the [ __ ] going on
but i was stressing though because my
brother was telling me [ __ ] going on
back home come up he got take care of
this he got take care of that i'm like
damn you hold all this [ __ ] down he
ain't even stressing you know i'm saying
it's like
[ __ ] man he's doing good he my younger
brother though
but just like
i just feel [ __ ] up because i know i'm
out here
but what brought you out to l.a
live a better life get away from the
violence
up on skid row because i had no money i
blew all my pua money
with my with my baby mama i got her
pregnant
but
you got a kid yeah i ain't never meet
him
or her
because my sister and him don't believe
his mind because they just don't want to
believe it because like
man you don't need no baby you feel me
they looking like you don't need no baby
right now
but i know i got a baby though
yo
have you ever worked have you ever had a
job yeah i working in the shipyard
sonics wendy's
mcdonald's
but my last job was on target warehouse
or either distribution
yeah
i'ma tell you about a story though man
that really brought me out here though
guy took any gun off his head
you feel me you ever heard of white wise
yeah yeah we got some [ __ ] called white
watch the big ass gasps
yeah
yeah i've seen it like a big air gas
station right
night time
so it was the [ __ ] i saw some adderall
two before
you feel me because i'd be getting my
eyebrows i said them you've been i'm
gonna put me on that [ __ ] oh god shout
out shout out to quality too man tonight
got there
keyshawn
got them beaming my [ __ ] turning stuff
back in
my [ __ ]
even though he did some grimey [ __ ]
shout out to him
so like everybody knew for news with jim
ain't for real
some real [ __ ] out there on god for
real the whole world forgot about
virginia we're the first state
family that's where the ancestors come
from of any black people in florida too
we got people out there too jacksonville
key west
oh god shout out them to anybody's out
there any hearings but yeah that day i
took [ __ ] get off his head
so god damn
i pulled my car and back his car opened
my door you feel me it was poised off
the puck right there by the gas pump you
see everything going on
late night had an f in 509 on his hip he
didn't know what he was doing with it
how about kill him and kill his three
friends
so look
he had one in the head though so i ain't
get to kill him all by the kill i put
the trick and everything so i put my car
i had an aqua 2006 tier
zero is 16 like two seconds i was a
young [ __ ] with it last year i [ __ ]
the car
every week [ __ ] the car broke his
head trying to do something with the car
speeding around and she getting tickets
forgot then i bet my car in front of him
and back his [ __ ] he couldn't go nowhere
he was already looking paranoid when i
did that had my door open
you feel me had my [ __ ] in parking all
that so i talked to him for a little bit
i said give me that [ __ ] i took it over
his head i pointed at him he started
running and ducking and [ __ ] so he's
staying right there you think i said
it's my [ __ ] now so i pointed at it i
put the trigger i said damn y'all got a
bullet in this [ __ ] you feel me but i'm
like damn i'm tripping i'm just got them
so pumped up i forgot to check the gun
and [ __ ] yeah i went ahead so i hopped
in the car sped up everybody like oh
[ __ ]
look what that boy doing and [ __ ] look
look look it's a guy i pull up i get
around the corner
i put one in the head i got there i laid
off like three times and she had my
goddamn car window shaking
you feel big ass fan five when i asked
you what
what's your biggest regret here
20 years yeah
living life too fast
and showing my brother the wrong way to
live life my younger brother me and him
close do you think he led him into the
same life yeah
i think that he
he looked at me like
because like when i was 13 i'm gonna
tell you what everything flipped the
script everything flipped the script for
everybody
anybody going through the same thing i'm
going through we all
went that little cycle we were like 13
you feel me
so you hit 13 you start smoking weed and
that's over after that overweight
some people don't need weed i ain't need
weed and i thought i did i ain't never
needed though i just always be around
the females i had all the females around
me like
i'm saying i want the freshest [ __ ] in
school but i always had females around
me i don't know what it was my
personality i just got their brain
energy
i'm saying i was smiling and [ __ ] but my
teeth was [ __ ] up you feel me i ain't
[ __ ] up as teeth hey hoes in my teeth
you think uh pot led to
all the other things that you got into
yeah having [ __ ] up chief yeah no but
i mean the the
gangs and guns and other drugs and stuff
like that well we yeah
uh
yeah yeah for sure yeah so if i end up
with smoking back in the day i wouldn't
be wasting money on the way i waste
money on today you feel me i spend a
whole hundred dollars a week
and think i'm good with it like i might
start working security soon though
you feeling me
hopefully next week
i'm gonna get my file for a minute out
here
you know what i'm saying so you're
you're out here trying to straighten
your life out yeah for so
so i'm trying to get rich i'm trying to
be an actor or a model i'm out of show
i ain't gonna lie i'll be seeing some
models out here that'd be ugly as hell
bro you feel like all right if i had a
good teeth bro all i need is a good
teeth bruh i gotta point with usc
dentist goddamn coming up too
like hopefully next month but once i get
my teeth right i'm good bro real [ __ ] so
what do you think the causes of all the
the
the gang activity the gang
all the wrong
so many teenagers getting involved
across the country across the country
yeah
other cities have it too it's not just
virginia in l.a i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say when we grow up we feel
depressed sometimes not having our dads
and not having our dads around and [ __ ]
not having any role models in your life
any good male role models nah
all them was murderers drug dealers
killers
had rapists of my family members
a lot of rapists in my family yeah role
models are huge you know what i'm saying
it's like nobody never showed me that i
i got touched on without like two
if i still remember to the date i got
touched on i said well i seen a video of
a young lady that had deal with you a
couple days ago or something like that
and she said that it she said she would
appear herself in front of the dude that
saved her little sister that's what i
had to do
say my little brother oh really yeah who
was who was mushing you yeah he was
molesting me who's this goddamn my momma
was [ __ ] with the military dude we
were young as hell like before we even
started school you feel me she got down
just before she got hooked on the pills
this one she was sober
so goddamn
she's a folk in the military knew his
nephews would come over
his one nephew has one niece and they
would be [ __ ] with each other they'll
assist their brothers they're from the
south
your family they would be having sex
with each other in the room while i was
in there and my little brother was in
there but my little brother made him a
year apart but he don't remember [ __ ]
and that's a good thing i'm glad he
don't or or he or he programmed himself
to forget all that [ __ ] so it's like
he'll pull his dick out and [ __ ] he'll
pee on me sometimes
he'll make me throw my mouth on it
[ __ ] like that but it's like
that's it when i when i grew up that's
it maybe never not trust nobody i feel i
never could trust nobody growing up you
feel me it's like that's always like
before i came out here i gotta kill
somebody with a gun i had an fn i was
hoping i could kill that dude i took it
from i wanted to kill him so bad but
god saved me from the bullet not going
on you know what i'm saying
i just had so much anger i still do to
the days like i don't trust no man
i'm looking upside down you deal with
most
anger yeah more than depression or yeah
not knowing who i am for real you feel
me that's that's what really lead to a
lot of this this [ __ ] with young men
not knowing who we are you feel me like
suburban kid they grow up knowing who
they is because they did everything in
the world yeah but what i see also is uh
very few
worthwhile role models yeah face that's
what it is if you had a dad
it was a stand-up dude you you probably
would have turned out very different
face so real [ __ ] though it's a real
[ __ ] if you didn't have other men like
touching you and doing crazy [ __ ] yeah
you probably would have turned out
different too but my mama when she
thought that she was going on she had
got out that relationship and he was in
the military and she was like
if she was like money hungry and [ __ ]
she would have stayed with him she
didn't really care about her kid but
that showed me she cared about us though
you sleeping in the car and everything
you feeling me
she got down she she took the turn about
that [ __ ] you think the gang violence is
an answer for anything
no it ain't though
it ain't no answer to it when you got
there and get into a game
like once you went into a game you do
[ __ ] because you don't want to be
seeming like you're a [ __ ] you don't
want to seem scary you know
man yeah you trying to prove your man
you feel me so you out here doing [ __ ]
that we don't even want to do but we got
to do it because that's what we at
that's how the police
expect us to act oh [ __ ]
if i'm homeless outside the hood the
police don't even give me a ride back
home
four five miles ago four five miles away
they're gonna make me walk you see what
i'm saying so we're like
it's a lot of [ __ ] bro that we gotta do
out here bro to survive bro we don't got
nobody by ourselves bro and our peoples
our mama or our daddy
and he probably not even around
so i'm saying this was like
yeah
that's wicked out there man for real
it's admirable that you're willing
you're trying to break out of it though
yeah i'm small percentage of people that
leave where i'm from
and i only got a money i'm not even a
college a graduate none of that i'm not
even a high school graduate the only
time you're going to leave from is if
you go to college
if you go to nfl
god damn anything like that military you
need to take it out that [ __ ]
for real you're foreign good credit i
never even knew about good credit
growing up
you saw i'm saying my momma know you
told us about that [ __ ] real [ __ ] all i
knew was guns sell drugs
and maybe be in the pit one day real
[ __ ] oh god
but now i i never be up him though it's
too much work
it's too much
it's crazy what'd you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your 20 years my most not no support
listen
take life serious
every day is a it's something every day
means something you're doing it yeah oh
god for real every day means something
take your time
seek the knowledge seek real knowledge
and i know [ __ ] knowledge out here
school teaching [ __ ]
yeah you're thinking for yourself yeah
you gotta learn we they need to start
teaching other folks in school how to
how to how to work a bank how to work a
bank account
how to build credit that's it's another
thing i see amongst all these people i
interview is nobody understands how to
handle money yeah if they have money in
their pocket they burn it yeah i spent
it i spent it so quick real [ __ ] my
brother he could save some money you can
save man he can maintain too i don't get
it he can finesse [ __ ] like that
whole outfit and still have all his
money in his pocket
real [ __ ]
oh god yeah delayed gratification is
like
unheard of yeah amongst all you see for
real i don't know that's i don't know
that means but yeah it sounds like i
mean like saving money for
something in the future perhaps
working hard now so you can like have a
reward later thanks that's right that's
what we got to start doing yeah you're a
smart kid you're you're
you you you're thinking for yourself and
you see things
that are possible whereas maybe a lot of
your friends back home were
just stuck in the same cycle of
violence in prison real [ __ ] man oh god
i see man i see so many shootings in my
face so many so many dead bodies
no cap i really see a lot of dead bodies
and shootings like
like [ __ ] can't really say that
for real
i've seen a lot of dead bodies
[ __ ] oh geez i grew up with
[ __ ] my age back in the day that guy's
killed over some [ __ ]
[ __ ] indeed back in the day like 2008
2010 uh harvard square cross street from
the circuit court this is outside of
newport news this is happening now yeah
this happened now you feel me man fast i
moved to downtown dupa news when i was
in high school nine grade you feel me my
mama yeah after we lost her six and
eight 2013
she just went down here he was homeless
for real after all that yeah
i've been homeless really since 2013.
keep it real with you all right
now ain't no stable housing
matt fan my mom did have one apartment
shoe standing in marshall courts
yeah
yeah um and hampton too we move
everywhere back and forth back and forth
hampton new blue and new if you from out
there you know i'm talking about real
[ __ ] it's back and forth back and forth
east city oh god bro
for real i'm from both for real but my
birth certificate say news
so i'm saying
maybe immaculate hospital
yeah i wish you the best of luck
straightening your life out out here
yeah bro just keep in mind that what
you're seeing on skid row
is not la and it's not the real world
it's it's it's some kind of weird it's
weird it's it's it's it's the bottom of
the barrel here it's a box it's a box
set up i watched the the videos on
youtube about skid row it's a box they
set up
so don't nobody i heard back in the day
they even let people pass certain
borders
go to the suburbs i was like damn
yeah i never do that where you from we
weren't even allowed bro that's because
they allow this [ __ ] to go on bro the
people here
they fought in love they don't find love
with the system but they're so weak
minded they're not strong but they don't
want a a real a real tough [ __ ]
gonna stand up for themselves bro i
don't give a [ __ ] about if you're
killing none of that real tough
[ __ ] it's killers out here that
i won't stand up for any damn stuff then
everybody get evicted i know that for a
fact bro i wanna probably not about the
lotto to step on us and say you gotta do
that we [ __ ] pulls off where we from
bro
real [ __ ] police officers not talking to
us crazy not putting a gun out on us
hell no because we got guns too
we're gonna yeah i know we're gonna do
to him
really say if i if i want to shoot i put
off i'm gonna shoot that one real [ __ ]
oh god for real if i feel like i got to
getting is it getting better or getting
worse
it's getting worse yeah
it's another thing that'd be going on in
california too i know this on youtube
bro i know
i'm saying you're a good dude i got to
meet you face to face
real [ __ ] it's like it's not it's a lot
of
pedophiles out here a lot of humor
trafficking going on
a lot of kidnapping going on yeah and
there's a goddamn it's the it's the
government line and [ __ ] real [ __ ] bro
it's like
bro
bro i seen the devil
i seen the devil from my own eyes no cap
real [ __ ] when i was in my was in my
bottom i was at the lowest energy in my
life
i see the real devil [ __ ] ain't had no
face [ __ ] was tall as hell dark skinned
[ __ ] he wasn't black but he was just a
go i don't know he looked black though
he had a hoodie on
no face under his hoodie
you feel me got around the corner seen
another creepy [ __ ] following me
that's all i'm gonna say though i seen
the real devil though i think you saw
jerry
yeah
[ __ ] i seen a real devil at two o'clock
in the morning i was getting off work
from science
yeah yeah that was down here skid row
yeah no no this is happening but this
this is in hampton virginia oh really
but look back to back there i was
talking my dog about the government [ __ ]
yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] they'd be loud
going on
and
and they'd be knowing these missing
people hey and they wait 20 years to go
to go get them you saw what i'm saying
so they did to their bones
you know i'm saying it'd be so sad bro
to be like
it's the illuminati illuminati is real
you feel me illuminati is [ __ ] up
a generation that's [ __ ] our people
they try to kill our people with black
people they try to kill our people
all right some people i say he created
nah i know i'm talking about
hell no
they trying to kill our people black
people all go crazy and start doing all
these crazy-ass drugs so we get hooked
on them and then we forget what real
life is
real life is
more than goddamn being holiday that's
what real life is that's all i'm going
to say so that's how i got there and
explained that's the best i can explain
like real life is is not being holiday
so even if you live holiday said know
what you're going to do with that high
you gotta have a hobby a son you gotta
have something going on
can't just be how they stuck in one
little box
you know what i'm saying you gotta have
a hobby
for real you got to find your hobby
while you still can't get an interest
yeah for real career interest or
something like that
oh god
well you got a good head on your
shoulders yeah for real start going to
the gym working out i'm trying to get
i'm trying to get like you g that's not
gonna work out like you bruh no [ __ ]
oh good it's easy you just gotta do it
your [ __ ] man get off your ass and do it
i went to here just high school and back
home i ain't never seen
yeah i went to hear this high school
yeah all right and it's here thank you
so much for talking with me man
very interesting yeah yeah i had no idea
real city oh god small town in virginia
has this crazy [ __ ] going on yeah
newport news south side newport news
happened to
yeah all right man thank you very much